protests sweeping the country in
response to the killing of George Floyd
by Minneapolis Police have reignited an
ongoing national conversation about
police brutality in black communities
[Music]
and in video after video of
demonstrators clashing with police the
protests are also revealing an
aggressive response to civil unrest that
has become common in American policing
so how did law enforcement come to use
these aggressive militarized tactics to
respond to the ordinance and how if they
continued today 20 years ago one protest
changed the way police respond to civil
disorder the 1999 demonstrations against
the World Trade Organization in Seattle
the 1999 WTO protests in Seattle were a
turning point for the American police in
terms of how they think about how to
handle a crowd events particularly mass
demonstrations the battle for Seattle as
it came to be known began peacefully but
escalated into multiple days of
confrontations mostly after police
attempted to disperse protesters with
tear gas and pepper spray after the
civil unrest of the 1960s the government
found that a forceful response from the
police actually escalated conference so
this led police to start using this
tactic called negotiated management
where they communicated with protesters
before demonstrations and agreed on a
plan and for several decades this was
how police managed protests until the
WTO demonstrations in Seattle
thousands of anti-globalization
demonstrators blocked the streets around
the Convention Center and things
escalated quickly
a small group of disruptive protesters
would not consult with the police so
this policy of negotiated management
completely broke down I was sent to the
WTO meetings in Seattle to cover the
environmental side I just started
covering the environmental beat for The
Wall Street Journal what I noticed at
the time though was that the Seattle
Police Department
steamed it they didn't seem like there
was very many police in comparison to
the protesters I was actually had a
little bit of you know I was nervous you
know I'm not sure why nervous was almost
like from
norm Stamper was the Seattle police
chief at the time we had 5060 thousand
people on the streets of Seattle this
city at the time of five hundred and
thirty thousand with about nine hundred
available police officers he says he now
regrets how he directed his officers to
handle the demonstrations I made the
biggest mistake of my career by
authorizing the use of chemical agents
against non-violent non-threatening
protesters what happened in Seattle is
really consistent with what we know from
a large body of research on crowd
psychology and we know that when crowds
feel that they're engaged in peaceful
lawful behavior then the police use
force against them or make mass arrests
against them the reaction is often going
to be defiance and rebellion rather than
sort of people just peacefully saying ok
I'm going to go home immediately after
the protests Stamper resigned
he has since dedicated the rest of his
career to police reform though there
were a few injuries and no deaths the
images coming out of Seattle depicted a
city that had lost control of its
streets and so control became a key
theme for police departments in the
aftermath Seattle really to me marked
the beginning of like a whole new era in
the way police dealt with protests to me
20 years later the greatest significance
of all is that the lessons we learned
are not generally being followed in the
rest of the country following Seattle
other law enforcement agencies around
the country realized that they had
events that were coming up that very
likely they would experience some of the
same protests that they had seen in
Seattle and some of the potential
disruption and they were going to need
to deal with this new way of doing
protest this leaderless disruptive not
willing to negotiate with police Howard
Jordan was the chief of police in
Oakland California during a key
hi protests and he said his officer
struggled with the leaderless structure
of the demonstration our policies you
know required us to meet with
demonstrators and try to come up with a
peaceful solution sort of you know work
out a deal where they stay on their side
of street and we stay on our side of
Street and that's it but as time went on
over the years even today obviously that
stuff kind of went away in the early
1990s the US Department of Defense
created the 1033 program which gave
unused military equipment to local law
enforcement free of charge
the Justice Department also started
giving money to local agencies for
policing programs training and equipment
after September 11th and the ensuing
wars abroad the militarization of US law
enforcement kicked into a new gear the
newly created Department of Homeland
Security started granting money to
States for equipment and training
related to anti-terrorism strategies
that kind of combination of ratcheting
up the police response to the
anti-globalization protesters and then
being concerned about the presence of
terrorists in these crowd events these
things led American police to really
adopt much more intensive much more
invasive approaches for handling these
events and then came the unrest in
Ferguson Missouri after Michael Brown an
unarmed black teenager was shot and
killed by police more than 50 law
enforcement agencies were involved in
the response to Ferguson and revealed a
complete breakdown of communication and
strategies the police response to the
protests in and around Ferguson was was
it was really almost a case study of
sort of how not to respond to these
incidents it also exposed just how
militarized local law enforcement had
gotten in response the Obama
administration started restricting
standards on the provision of
military-style equipment to local police
departments later they created a task
force on American policing and released
a comprehensive report detailing what
went wrong at Ferguson laying out policy
plans for police reform despite the
efforts of the Obama administration the
response to today's protests have shown
that the equipment and tactics used by
police are not standardized President
Trump
signed an executive order reversing
Obama's restrictions on military
equipment in 2017 and has called himself
the law-and-order president law
enforcement agencies across the country
still hold billions of dollars worth of
tactical equipment but the recent
protests are already leading to changes
there's a renewed push by lawmakers to
shut down the surplus military equipment
program and some cities have started
restricting the use of chemical and less
lethal weapons by police there's also a
growing movement to defund local police
departments and reinvest that money it's
not good for law enforcement
we just took 20 years we'll just went 20
years backwards okay that's that's not
we're not gonna recover from it anytime
soon
Stamper says he understands the
complexity of systemically reforming the
police but seize this moment as a golden
opportunity as I do believe after all
the years and clamoring for police
reform we're at a crossroads the timing
could not be better for legitimate
reform